- Dans ce point de dépôt
au centre-ville de Montréal,
on peut rapporter toutes sortes
de canettes et de bouteilles,
dont les bouteilles de vin,
qui seront bientôt consignées.
L'endroit est géré par
la coopérative Les Valoriste
qui participe à l'un des sept
projets pilotes mis sur pied
par Québec pour tester
l'élargissement de la consigne.
ALEXIS-MICHEL SCHM
gérant Coop. Les Valoristes
- Quand il y a un système de
consigne qui fonctionne bien,
ça fait qu'il y a un recyclage
en moins.
Puis on le voit en Colombie-
Britannique, on le voit
aux États-Unis; et c'est ça que
le Québec est en train de fa
en ce moment, c'est de rattraper
ce 10 ans de retard dans lequel
on était jusqu'ici.
- Que ce soit les bouteilles
d'eau, de vin ou e
les contenants de lait et
de jus, tous les récipients de
plastique, de verre et de métal
d'un volume de 100 millilitres
à 2 litres seront
à partir du pintemps 2023.
Des consignes de 10 cents
dans la plupart des cas
et de 25 cents pour les gros
contenane.
L'objectif : éviter que 50 000
tonnes de matières recyclables
se retrouvent au dépotoir
chaque a
BENOIT CHARETTE, ministre Env.
Lutte contre changements clim.
- J'espère que ce matin,
e le signal
comme quoi c'est irréversible,
on va de l'avant et que oui,
ça va nous aider à changer
.
- C'est ceux qui mettent
en marché et qui distribuent les
nouveaux contenants consignés,cs
et les supermarchés, qui seront
responsables de les récupérer.
Le réseau devra compter 1500poie
pour desservir la population.
Impossible, rétorquent
les épiciers, même si Québec
a repoussé de six mois l'entrée
en vigueur du nouveau système.
PIERRE-ALEXANDRE BLOUIN, pdg,
Asso. détaillants alimentation
- Nos magasins ne sont pas faits
pour gérér la consigne 2.0
et ça, on le répète depuis
le début du processus.
- Faute de place dans
leurs commerces pour traiter
les nouvelles matières
recyclables, les détaillants
devront probablement
se regrouper pour ouvrir
des points de dépôt,
ce qui pourrait nécessiter
aux de conaux de conaux de conan
et donc des délais.
- On parle d'entente entre
les détaillants. Il faut
qu'on puisse s'entendre avec
urrents dans plusieurs
communautés. C'est beau sur
papier, mais quand on regarde
tous les détails dans le projet
de règlement, on esttrès préocc.
KAREL MÉNARD, dg, Front commun
gestion écologique des déchets
- On parle quand même à terme
de 5 milliards de contenants.Doe
une logistique, éventuellement
avoir des entrepôts provisoires
pour faire de la consolidation
de contenants et tout,
donc on a encore énormément
de travail à faire.
- Quand il est que